[Music]
you are part of the family so much of
the good in my life is because of you
for centuries no human has had the power
to become a
monster until now
behold the transformation ray awesome
but is this safe though let's find out
huh
is everything okay down here hey drac
what's up johnny oops
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
[Music]
you're human drag oh no i have a total
dad bod
um what is going on
what's up
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me i've literally
never seen you before
we need to find a way to fix this
there is a place deep in the amazon only
there can the transformations be
reversed and the goal
wow flying his monster is so much better
right
feeling
you're not a vampire the sun won't fry
you now it's glorious it's wondrous it
it's burning my eyes
if we don't fix you guys through you'll
be like this forever seriously everybody
relax
just enjoy the view ah please
being a human is the worst and swim
can't relax mosquitoes
hotel transylvania transfer mania
boy that was fun the only place to
experience transfer mania
[Music]
you